well today my my goal is to is to get
everybody up to speed on problem three
to make sure that we that we understand
young some of the issues and we're
getting into perhaps unless somebody
already has covered the set of all stuck
at faults by 10 test cases if we haven't
solved it already then by the end of
today at least we'll be we'll be ready
to to move full full steam on so what I
wanted to do for starters was to take a
look at that simple half add circuit as
an example of a much smaller circuit
then the then the big four hundred gate
one and see if we can't get some some
insight into the large problem by
studying a small one in in some detail
let me try to write that down against
the half at circuit had had inputs XY
and Z and and we formed result one which
was the exclusive or of x and y call
that a and then we had the end of x and
y I guess I didn't plan this too well
and call that B and then we had the
exclusive or of a and Z that's one of
the outputs you
and we have the end of a MZ it's getting
worse okay not just the end and call
that C and finally we have B or C which
is called v4 or I guess okay so that's
we know that's not a very good diagram
but that's why preferred to give it
algebraically in fact of course hardware
people use all kinds of special symbols
I don't know what yeah what you know the
various things forgave you so on I I
don't think they have enough symbols for
all the different boolean functions in
any way exclusive or it looks pretty
good that way so on so we also have the
the straight line description which is
like used in in in compilers that gives
you what they call a dag a directed
acyclic graph on where we said that a is
equal to X exclusive ry b is equal to x
and y SI is equal to a and Z and that
was you the outputs u is equal to a
exclusive or Z and B was B or C now this
was the this is the circuit that has two
outputs and three inputs it in the idea
is that if we if we are trying to add 3
31 bit numbers together then this gives
us the two bits of their some so the
units bit is going to be you and the the
tenth the twos bit will be V so that's
going to represent whether or not the
sum X plus y plus Z is two or more is V
and then you is going to be X plus y
plus Z mod to the other jealousy so this
adds three binary numbers and gives us
and gives us a two bit
okay now the question to ask on this is
let's try to make let's let's try to
look at the stuck-at faults on it there
are 10 possible stuck at faults however
we don't consider the ones that the out
maybe see i guess we do consider the
ones that the output yeah but they're
they're sort of obvious what what would
happen now i mean if you is stuck at 0
in order to in order to detect that
fault we would have to find some input
which makes u equal to one and that's uh
you know x plus y plus Z is odd we'll do
that similarly V so let's take a look at
one at a which is which is one of the
more interesting gates and try to see
what we would have to do in order to
have a stuck-at suppose a is stuck at
zero and just look at that sub problem
for it so suppose a is stuck at zero how
would we catch that what would be a test
case that that detects a stuck at 0 so
welcome eat it XO why he was it up over
okay so first of all you want if you
want x so first of all you want X plus y
equals 1 this great on say is that's
going to be good enough to get to detect
that a is stuck at du poids ET on this
day you also must know it's got to
propagate through a physical health it's
got a propagate to a visible output
because these one that it will check and
catch it boise's wanted will it then
then you apply the wrong value or stores
your
it doesn't matter if ya okay so it does
so in fact this one does propagate since
since the exclusive-or always are
changes its state if it's one of its
input is wrong then in fact you will be
drawn if a is wrong all right let's try
be problems well that's it ok so a stuck
at one which I guess we could even we
can make a systematic chart so how about
a and then we have stuck at zero and
stuck at one and like a b c you and B
and the case is that that a is stuck at
0 is a 1 well this is one I guess so
we've actually characterized them all on
is that ex ex ex exclusive or with y is
1 so i want to i want to write a short
hand notation for for that and i think i
can call it X X bar Z for in other words
any any input for which y is equal to X
bar the complement of X will will will
detect a stuck at 0 what's the
corresponding entry for a stuck at one
on Andrew x/x x x v as the same argument
works it's just that we got to have a
duty we gotta have a value that produced
that makes a incorrect we also have to
have values that makes the result
visible and least one output put it it
so xxz will do it okay so b is the next
one
I be stuck at zero and so there we want
any1 we also want B to be visible let's
give it at this move very because
because ex exclusive or while will be
zero exciting but this ex exclusive or I
will be 0 so the emergency will be ones
that have at least 10 you have x and y
must be one okay so now we've got X and
X gluten so so we got a zero coming in
here but the largest 80 in C so that
makes a zero okay no matter what Z is
but ok with notre site so here we're
using while backward forward propagation
of of arbys we said that since b is 1
then x and y its inputs must both be one
there for coming downwards this must be
0 therefore this must be 0 and therefore
it will propagate through the door so
it's also be off the example for be
stuck at 0 are 113
okay how about being stuck at one all
right so here we've got me stuck at one
and we want to get it through to our
output V movies are xx 0 for X X company
anything oh ok so you've looked ahead
how did you get given the steps because
we want a computer to be able to do this
group for you want into the other input
to be to be anyone in order to get
through this over here tell what the
other input to get 0 the only it's the
only way that becomes to the output this
through is through this way and and so
you see in the in the case of the
exclusive or if that wasn't a plus here
we a was coming through would have a
chance to come through and infect v also
but we group we had it already detected
at you so he didn't need it or at least
what that means one output has to be
affected but but not yet not every
output but be appears only in V so they
don't know what to get to get through
the value of b if c were if c were one
then then now it doesn't matter what B
is so we have to have a zero at this
point so we also have to help Dave and z
is equal to 0 ok and now on so a was the
exclusive or of x and y and so you g0
fix water bill 0 if x and y are both 0
they dead level is he if x and y are
both 0 then kinsey is Vince than 80 but
if x is 0 and why it's not 0 then then Z
has to be 0 so so we had been 00 can
anything now we had X X bar and 0 with
it
and those were the two cases so here we
have 0 0 mb or XX x 0 everybody with me
on that means don't be afraid to say no
because I don't want to want to lose
people but i'd only go to slow eating so
I know I got to have some feelings of
control I've been asking for volunteers
for answers but not volunteers for I
should pick on somebody at random to
find out yes better okay n.n scene is
another one let's complete the table
maybe we can do it in our sheds let me
take at random I got like about your
random arch are okay see stuck at 0 how
do we respect your gonna make see one
seems young enz one you'll need 1 of x
and y ok tell you but you also exactly 1
of x and y se me there is a supplement
their this early the 0 to do that will
skew 20 to be which is pink so the RX x
bar and now and now our that makes C
equal to 0 of the one weapons vc is
equal to 1 and therefore stuck at 0
ought to be detective provided that b is
equal to 0 let's Jones legend is I
indeed it's good 0 cos x x bar 0 ok
right okay Roger i ragazzi start out
next week because the season at one how
can we do see stuff that one well jim
has to reach the young
to reach the output so log x + y + you
want the one be being zero ok be as
they're all that's that's this guy again
anyone let's see you want to make c0 so
you have to have either 0 or x and y you
go on so it looks like what we did I can
lie on equal yeah it seems there are x
and y equal to 0 maximum line the
exclusive or equal 0 so no okay I mean
it looks like the same two iterations
that we had for be stuck at one this is
that please there's no right so we have
okay so up we got to get the same answer
okay John but this is too easy easy yes
but let's write it down click the table
for this big cake so for instance when
you is ok ok pull that no x and y then
see if you do express it in terms of
Mexico yeah because if if ex my ex parte
want why you're doing to in terms of two
sets again we have x x / 0 yeah just a
hard isn't a shin how about this no this
will make me one point right for stuck
at 0 um just gives the value of you x
close the moral wife who's the work it
will be 0 and so this is we're stuck at
one go on so this would have been the
correct putting the ball over is also
that exclusive or with one okay now on
so you can you can consider the two
cases that x equals y and x is unequal
why so um you know for example x x bar
and then that makes wanderin so we need
0 or X X 1 all right okay why do we put
here put 0
are we Scalf is it again yeah it's I
think ok let's go John tell us about
vegan can fill out our table gun and
let's see okay that's the same isn't
actually the detecting a see stuck at
one you want on which days you didn't
get that backwards from d oh really
foresee stuck at one we want c to be
zero so that x and y have to be either
equal or zs to be zero to sleep the CC
has to be 0 and I grew up equi skin and
that's a and Z equal zero so this is the
equal 0 the other thing case would be
equals zero in order to get through they
are right now it's the stuff i mean you
have I think I think you want 00 Nazi
and then on our tree you want you want
you want you to have not see her you
want to have and I said why I told some
other with our answer for being was also
wrong I'm saying is it not as pretty
soaked Isis well but the answer for beer
that one has is the same as the answer
versus see that one isn't it because we
said that for for be stuck at one we
needed be to be 0 and see the detail for
a scene stuff at Langley need to see a
b0 babies there if you see stock up on
we need a equal to zero or c is equal to
zero why because b doesn't feed in to
see this video if you go to be output so
they would be atlas believe already
feeds into me yeah so it's always
helpful to questions of logic it's
always helpful to have pencil and paper
handy i think in tuition somehow fails
this is the i mean that you have all
these things that comes about one tribe
tells the truth and went red line random
is on the solution this always seems to
say well here you can check this out
with pencil on paper and in every case
it works but I don't know anybody really
into its these these solutions and feel
and so sees them happening you just
check the stated secretary now let's
check this one again because it might be
wrong to stuff at least i play with the
parentals up a few lines that would be
the same man of the right answer so if
exit i are both 0 then z is arbitrary
because that will make B and C both 0 if
x and y are not both 0 then 1 is 0 and
and the other isn't so a is 1 and so
zine has to be 0 the second Casey
so like I said thing you can put in
there is naught X x0 not X and X 0 is
another thing you could add however I
would probably try to call that not wine
one but ain't coming correct it's a free
variable and not exa brings over the
same values as if so so what I mean by X
in this notation is probably what's
going you up this means either 0 or 1 X
bar so it says help it's a shorthand for
two solutions the number of free
variables that I put in here indicates
the number of cases and I think we've
used with this common is actually over
disjoint sets the way we've got it so
here i found how many solutions for a
stuck at 0 how many things before x is
eating pattern here we've got two ways
to do it here only two ways to do it
here we got two plus two is four we got
two plus two is four so the number of
ways to do it is my dissing big was the
thing okay now what about me then now
one bead we say stuck at 0 so the in
order to get V stuck at 0 or its
equivalent the same that is I mean for
that to be a frog it should be equal to
1 so what are the cases that make it
equal to 1 first to them
so we want beautiful wine and now
because 0 0 excuse me and then then we
also have the condition that green gets
to an output to be detected however that
condition is known this day is included
to the two conditions that be stuck at
21 RC Statoil V is stuck at one or see
it stuck at 10 seconds okay so we have
vehicles of all uses of edges it's just
going to be the two out of three is 110
x expert is the 200 sorry i was looking
at the one condition okay stuck at one
so that's perfect so b is equal to x and
y is also be equals x 0 y 4 c is a and Z
equals 1 cjk just look at what he needs
it's easier to look at what being means
yeah but it's always a computer scan it
this is in fact if we look at what V
means and we can be mean stuff x plus y
plus Z train or equal to it's a majority
function threshold function they call it
a logic function that's truly if and
only if the the number of ones and the
input is greater drinko some bomb but
we're trying to also imagine as we saw
this that we were computers presented
with a 400 gate circuit and we want to
have extrapolate to imagine data
structures and algorithms walking up and
down so on as we're doing this exercise
too so so I was being a little more
mechanical in this so we have two cases
either be as one or osseous is one or
both although the knowing what the
answer is going to be is but it is going
to help us check it but listen let's
forget that well while we derive the
answer just try to be mechanical so so
suppose we take case one the B is one
then that tells us what about this
the XY the special effects yeah so
that's a one month G is a solution ok
that's another solution X expertise ok
assuming X 6 / 16 is that is there is
one MZ is one which is X X bar one
contender let's turn out to be
disjointed that although I mean just
because it turned out that the B and C
vot cannot both be true simultaneously
we got another gate in the circuit that
was calculating BNC it would be very
hard to detect if that it was stuck at
zero because it would always be see I
mean that wouldn't be an error because
the body has to be there BMC if we work
at it that way in this circuit somewhere
else it's possible to design circuits
that have fun so that all combination to
the input will infect produce outputs of
zero or outputs a one and in which case
will be very hard to detect default on
that gate since the gate is redundant
unless the fault unless the gate is
stuck at the wrong thing well I'm so
isn't it kind of a problem to simplify
the circuit first because he get rid of
this case which could be stuck at the
opposite yeah the there are some
simplifications that we know can be made
without looking at the inputs for
example if if they gate if well ok and
again the problem that you have there's
a simplification that says if one of the
inputs is zero then you know the output
and so you don't you don't put the gate
in the circuit at all if you have an and
gate and one of the inputs of zero and
the output is zero if you have an or
gate 1 equal to zero the output is the
same as the input and we just hard what
your we just you just imagine
circuit we don't met we don't put a gave
in and so it never goes into the data
structure but a represent a but somehow
we we keep track of this as we're
building this the data structure with me
episode the other kind of simplification
is a gate that never actually used in
any of the outputs I think our but there
are about a dozen of those in a circuit
that they're actually gates are are are
are explicitly specified in that module
but they don't ever appear in any output
as he said the ones that have an and
gate with the sural impetus in the
specification you give but it's not
really in the circuit so I really in the
circuit okay yeah it disappears and it
drops the circuit down by a factor to it
three I think in me I forget what the
what the numbers weren't taking what it
does yup that's that that kind of
simplification is done all right however
suppose there were supposed somebody
also had another circuit in this case
you know and also put in hand gate in
here between B&C close there was a DNC
and another output w-was it that that we
had added this to a you know a triple
adder some kind of a thing that's better
than a half adder we get a patent on and
and so we we have his new gadget here w
equals BNC and now I've seen oh my legs
to make a test case which is going to
check for W stuck at zero so in that
case we would we would need to find a
case where w is equal to one and it
never is equal a lot so so this would be
a fault but we couldn't test for I think
there are actually gets like that in the
circuit you gave us you think that
there's also there are some gates that
are there they're known to have a
constant output in the circuit we gave
okay well let's get to that later
because that will be important news in
far as well wait but it was latest if
the gate is always going to get the same
then again at redundant shouldn't be
part of the circuit that's right we're
so we could eliminate from the circuit
there are gates like that which don't
have to i did the fear fertilizer voice
to butter the 30 31 and there was a gate
like that a camera okay in a three by
three case yeah well let's take a look
at that later good fine lines so anyways
at this point the means B and C cannot
both be true and we have to face up to
the fact that that this might happen
music and the reason I thought of that
in this problem is that well I had two
cases one or the other and if i were to
trying to look for for well after i
solved the first case to solve the
second one i could assume that be with 0
and like I could say I could take you
know instead of this or I can say seeing
is this and being equal 0 because I've
already considered the case B equals 1
and so then this would be the exclusive
or mean would you this case or of this
case bonamo and on but in this case is a
when c is 1 b is equal to 0 so that's
this is in this particular circuit the
to pick the two things aren't mutually
exclusive so these were the cases that b
is sum is equal to 1 and are greedy
means that we have at least two of the
X's and Y's and 2 of x y and z are are
on either either x and y are both on or
Z is on and one of the other two okay
now what's the other case then of be
stuck at one if that's the last thing in
on table these stuck at one let's figure
it out this means that this has to be 0
ok now let's go too long Amy see that we
need x and y equal yeah the DNC both
have to be doing ex exclusive or Y & Z
goes so you could have X and X naught 0
is ok so let's funny so you're saying X
X naught 0 0 of x and y is your
basically tells me mm-hmm fact that I
music right at the other wake of its
familiar anything so sing this turns out
that here we had three different ways to
get the same mom these interests of you
type of the same the same stuck at fault
okay now this is a complete table
showing exactly all in all the cases of
breach fault not in our problem we don't
need a complete table it's not it might
be might be it might take an hour to or
no might click a long time here's all
the inputs that that produce a certain
stuck at fault and not chart like this
you know a list like this might get very
long on a much larger circuit and we
could also list them out if we need to
but but only one of these is is good
enough we just have to cover each fault
we don't have to we don't have to find
all ways of doing it we just have to
find one way of doing each one and
if we if we decide for example that
we're in poreotics wouldn't look at this
one and forget about that one we might
not get the minimum cover of Alton stuck
at faults but but we what we you might
have a good chance because per month
they're usually on a minimum cover
problem there's many many ways to get
the same minimum and so just take take
one that looks pretty good might be good
enough I on the other hand if we
restricted ourselves to just taking the
first case that has a stuck-at fault
suppose we suppose we we just choose one
like you know x equals 0 and z equals 1
or something in that case then then
we're only finding that then we've been
were we're saying nom we probably need a
lot of test cases so it's desirable to
to know as many of these of these things
that cause the falsest as you can
conveniently but still it's not
necessary to know all of them if that's
going to take you too much time is it
there's a trade-off between between
exhaustion and and expediency the
problem will be probably i think the
total problem of finding the absolute
minimum cover would be expensive enough
that i wouldn't want to pay the bill i
would want to you know increase the
national debt by but I asking for
funding for for all the computer time it
would be taken to find the exact minimum
maybe someone will figure out a way to
do to make me wrong so my point is that
here we have complete information but
but any subset of this ne9 empty subset
of these entries could also lead to age
a way of covering all the false and you
want to take the largest convenient
subset probably
um now let's see now Mike you said in
the in the case of of say at multiplying
free bit by three bit you found a gate
that was the side of the Chula to
industry but through that ok sir can you
describe which gate it is this one of
these it was I good enough if figure it
is what other gates that boost one of
the top two bits in it was an order of
two things one of the things as always
erotic today ok so so you found that in
the in the final phase of Barbara's we
see are trespassing but you didn't
identify it further ok so so the last at
well actually we never in our final add
brother to let's at least open and
there's a 4-byte visit is that we're
adding 382 two numbers together what is
I don't know what they put the right
location in for us let's all I mean I'm
using I know it's the wrong location and
then the field mystic mistaken for us
different they work that's flora to the
right one this is a witness we have a
paralyzer for two for two things and the
first thing we do is is in his parallel
adder is that we can I mean these are
going to add together the the the
results of all the different partial
products and we reduced it by Jake
changing 3 2 2 3 2 2 3 2 until finally
only 20 left and this is going to be the
final coup de Gras the end of them of
the multiplication will be the sum of
these two numbers and we did a parallel
add on these and let's see what the
formulas were at Z 3 Z 2 Z 1 Z 0 0 I
think what Z sub K was equal to XK plus
YK
and then we have dumb and see let's do
it the way the way it really looks on
them on a two-bit case like how do you
know the info is here so how did you
know the other input was always your own
was a king of it it was I was just going
to criticism and of was something like
the end of an end and of two bits next
over to bits and those together or
something like that memory executive
okay well let's just take a look at the
petrol zpl Buddhism body selected or
something if I think it will be useful
on let's sit so then we had also are
there was another thing called done
let's say don't I'm sorry about spot the
notation here WK was equal X K and like
him and then and then what we did was we
called the routine c 1 of 0 and b w w0
w1 w2 with 0 Z 1 Z 2 Z 0 Z 1 Z 2 I think
that's what it is and then we call c and
this this computes this goes to say c 8
oh gosh a c6 c7 c64 i'll have to find a
better notation for this or we could we
can put it into the notes we had last
week if i could remember exactly what
the notation was last week now this done
then we did a c2 on this guy on c7
through c0 oops see you look like a
numbered it wrong 01
23 okay so all this backwards and then
we did a Stanley do a c2 of this and
that goes to the output that goes to d0
to d7 and then finally the final circuit
was to add this guy
so you're doing to bits by two bits is
that right let's take two by two because
it's going to be it's going to be like
me I won't get too bogged down if you do
to buy to the two like who gives us four
then we get these oh ok well that might
help when you see lefties what did i do
though at the end I add 15 bits ok so 15
is now 4 so that's this is it i just add
the b3 how it'll be fi 0 so it looks
like i take be 3d 2d 120 mrs. plus this
so we get the final answer what's going
to be the exclusive or of these guys so
that we actually computed if you
remember from last time we had the we
had the sums of of the exclusive or not
you know some smart two of the extra and
then we had two exclusive or on Carrie
digits that came from before and so the
Saudi three is going to represent the
condition there's a carry from the right
of this point and d2 is going to
represent to simmer soon no is it
possible that d3 will always be 0 or
that
hmm I mean as always yeah there they
suffocate you chuckles no I'm in a boat
oh but in calculating be free well so
let's take a look at the cut be honest
what is this what what if this one do d0
doesn't that mean that you're
simplification is wrong if you get those
gates like that as we discussed earlier
my simplification no wrong yeah so on
what do you mean not worried that if the
first stage of the of your program
simplifies the circuit properly it
shouldn't get any games news outlets
always are the same value it's simple i
there's a really good it may be hard to
catch them but if you do catch them all
and simplified then you get rid of this
is that gives extract that that if we
catch all the zeros then we don't get
any other simplifications like we have
an exact we have an example here it's
just religious kitchen so those are some
but there are other situations that'll
tell me things like I it's an exclusive
or gate should have enough both of its
inputs connected to the same place yeah
we're banana gave orphan or get a xanax
and an X invert and the next not coming
into it right damn you know but it's
that its output is is up it's a very
short you know it's not really I mean
that's good for those days is it but I
mean their audiences are vegetables yeah
so so I believe there are situations
might think that facade right where this
could happen as nicknaming that no
matter you exhaust all the all the
popular let's for example let's suppose
we're multiplying numbers maybe this can
happen in number theory but but this
would be an interesting way to prove it
it can't happen support suppose we look
at something in our final in our final
product here and the only way to get a
certain gate to come up a certain
condition to occur is if the if the
final number after the addition is equal
to all ones for example both but if that
number are runs is a prime then it would
have to then have been what x and y when
you multiply x times y would
out to all ones since it's a prime so
there won't be you know so every every
every final answer that we come through
here it's going to be something that's
that that can be written as a product of
two two-digit numbers so there are
certain cases that are excluded by
number think one of them may be one but
a two-digit number is small so so there
so you know there are there are lots of
of you know there's number theory
somehow this gives me an test for
formality is somehow being a code and
use a man or gates here are not
primarily but but test for on are not
having a large prime factor or prime
factor greater than certain number of
bits so so this is a why it might be
possible that some of these things don't
occur but I wanted to look in detail at
the at the K propagator circuit because
that's because it might be obvious that
the thing is always is always zero if we
look at the cary proper propagated
circuit so i'm trying to go back out of
my notation to this one you have them if
you can meanwhile all you got it listed
on the certificates I can't find any
examples and also a mistake distributor
so this is another example of tickets
that always preach the same result g5 is
all of its ended together this is the
entire circuit this is the two-bit
malaria is that it has simplified you're
supplying out for what is it did
penalize your language okay it also
don't contribute to the output so so
you're saying this is the entire circuit
for the 2 by 2 k's okay well i might as
well drive that down instead of getting
bogged down this
okay my god read it this way babies die
eventually it's a nice diagram okay and
the pedal and pepper good candy going in
it subsidy you have subside yeah it's
upside down ok so I'm irrelephant
reverse I think he has died from that
ridiculous this one looks a lot match
professional saw to this one what ok so
here we got them this guy and you got
this guy coming over here this is great
anything have all these oh boy then
there's is and gave here so this is G 0
which is this will be stand for an end
ok and g1 g2 g3 and now we know about
those we want to take eyes ero and it on
to i2 and i3 and that gives us 20 and g
2 and similarly the other guy well maybe
it must be this must be the wife ok then
this is our final output 0 0 this one an
exclusive or gate
24 that's known as circle plus that one
comp that one with with this and then
there's a g5 which is an and gate
corresponding usually exclusive always
have the corresponding ends next home
and so that's disc put them and then g3
into g six and so to g5 whoops on the g6
as an and gates are right and then we
also took this into exclusive or gate
here I'm almost on the track gang t9
this is all three this is 0 2 and this
is 0 1 so the claimants in that case
that one of these gates us has a
constant value this was after this this
doesn't have a big cheesy but we're good
always have the same else there's an
exam v6 and GT I've always have the same
output so does it because what g5 is i0
and i1 and i2 and i3
35 is equal to I its a0 and a1 affects
you it's the end of an end and and these
are either this is I 093 this one is i1
and i2 okay so chief 25 is the end of
everything is that d 5 will be 1 if and
only if they're already pull along yeah
it's been g6 you're ending your endings
from the back in again just finish
engine he says we're done stuff oh okay
so you don't just get rid of cheese
sticks so so you're saying a g6 it's a
is equal which is Jeanne fry and g3
could end but I don't have any
complimenting in this circuit so once
always stay one so that g6 will have to
therefore always come out to be the same
as chief I'm so it's a redundant aid in
that sense now that's it that's it but
it doesn't have however do you could
detect a bucketful yeah everything you
had something going from then into an X
on which is look how from the two
between the tomb of the right so now if
we had g5 x rg6 we would know that the
the XR is always equal to 0 because
they're always equal that is the problem
finding on guitar here's this
I don't there's something that can be
challenged really other than trying all
to the 16th inputs to make a big case or
buy something on the backward part about
the situation sometimes it yes sorry so
there is a way okay yeah sounds gonna be
easy I don't know it is which is smaller
than what Marcus English there's just a
problem is the trade-off between trying
all inputs versus during satisfiability
problem i guess there isn't and now
there are many ways to to take to study
problems that are exponential pardon and
that it depends on other constraints is
to hug which one we want to try at a
particular time we might wind up if we
have six teams six different approaches
and not always clear which one is going
to be faster depending on how for
example pascal doesn't have a good way
to do forward of exclusive or of of
numbers but if you're writing in c you
can do that so you could be testing 32
cases how the circuit doing forward
boolean operations in c by just it now
by bike bike by setting up by your your
your x y&z to be 32-bit numbers put
different ones you know running through
the circuit you get 32 bit output which
gives you a third which gives you thirty
two examples of the law of what happens
and so if you know this on the other
hand if you're using another another
language that might not be a good way to
you know you might be might be
handicapped by not be able to do forward
boom operations that are in your
hardware
hmm I wanted to see if I can't figure
out the the okay well i think i'll just
refer that so if there's a possibility
though that somewhere in the last stages
of the of the addition that there will
be a gate that's known whose output is
known to be zero it can never be true
that a gate is known to be one in this
case because we don't have any ways to
turn 0 into one if all the inputs are 0
everything is going to be 0 we don't
have any inverter it's only and it's
it's only answers and exclusive or
dizziness in this problem now the next
thing I wanted to to discuss this
morning is suppose you have a set and
the suppose we take the dual problem
instead of starting with a stuck-at
fault and saying what inputs produce the
stuck-at faults let's start with an
input and say what stuck at false does
this input detect so so let's go back
and see if we can solve a corresponding
problem so now i'll sell my input for
example 000 which faults would be stuck
at which would that detect
so now so much my inputs for example 000
which faults with this topic which would
that detects and so here we have a zero
stable away what can this table already
um well that's what do you think we
should do g 0 B 1 c 0 c a0 b0 b1 let's
just so we have a possible inputs but
let's let's suppose that we take one of
these are random and figure out which a
WIC stuff at fault ahead let's pretend
we don't have this job to look at but
that we're taking is at a separate kind
of a subroutine so if somebody has given
us a an input and we would like to know
which stuck at possibly pick up so let's
pick up let's go predictably the other
table and say that we have x equals 0 y
plus 1 equals 1 that means then that a
fourth X exclusive or Y is equal to 1 B
is x and y 2 0 c is km z is 1 u is equal
to a plus B which is 0v is finally the
RC this is one okay so which which stuck
at faults do we do we detect Chris
tricky only played only detect ones
which are the opposite of Thursday
okay so first of all it's going to be if
aaa-0 would be a a it might be said a
stuck at 0 we might you might detect
being stuck at one see stuck at 0 you
stuck at one or be stuck at 0 we might
detect but there's another condition can
see I'm sure that it affects the output
also look for you and view that's
obvious but you and be it it's it's too
so and what about what about for the
other one so gerne is there a fairly
easy way to to understand in a circuit
whether or not if you know the very
values of the other variables if you
know whether or not you get through the
Aqua Constance even one you're not going
to see be okay
since he is one you're not going to see
be because it'd be all it literates be
so these yours you are going to CC perk
yeah well in general the only ways to
mess kit are boring with a winner and
another zero are going through our wait
a minute yeah yeah okay let's do it slow
motion pouring with a one will mask it
adding with the zero we'll mastered
version arif as I was talking about the
four you can also not all things safe
elusive are with your cell phone this
box those are going with yourself Will's
for public without general premise
inhaler yeah if you allow things to
feedback like that then you also have to
worry about hanging with the compliments
and exploring with yourself for mr. so
yeah it's actually there is no feedback
and he said that that you could bridge
it's okay it's possible to have for
example a circuit that's fantastically
okay you have a stroke good girl a key
part of your circuit arm and and its
output comes out here and it's supposed
to be 0 but it's reading really comes
out one and now here you still um okay
you will use at two places maybe you
would loose avoid here with somebody and
inclusive over here with somebody else
now if you come back here and exclusive
are these together again then this one
it's not affected by the by the by the
by the wrong officer to this car for
example in there are other there are
other cases like that now I'm so so
simply having a clear path of exclusive
orders to the output it's not he's not
sufficient to get to to get to the
output yeah this is gonna end you know
it's I'm not bad
this is but it's just having them just
just the existence of a path of
exclusive orders from a gate to the
outfit doesn't mean that Chuck thank you
always be able to check up the game okay
so so um suppose that that we tried okay
thank you I like this problem because
you get to try to prepare down to
programming that you but the professors
teaching and how I'm saying I try to
imagine for example finding some sub
problem so tell me something variants
that you could solve for example me
maybe with each gate we could we could
we could consider associated with at the
set of all stuck at faults that that we
could have obtained if if we have only
the circuit up to that gig you see what
I mean I start out with it with a
circuit with the circuit that's trivial
and X I say that the only stuck at
faults that I don't know is that we call
i started after a then i suppose i have
a circuit has only be a and then I and
then the then I try to evaluate a
function at a saying this is the set of
all stuck at faults in the circuit that
that I can that I that I could do then I
try to to consider the operation if I
have the exclusive or of if i add an
exclusive or two to the to the network
and i already know the set of stuck at
faults that that are produced at the two
sons of that exclusive are 0 then what's
the set of struck out coughs up for the
for the new gate and sort propagate
downwards that way that's just i am
going to solve the problem now i'm just
pointing out it that then you might want
to to look at that in this particular
case although let's finish this problem
let's see what you also have to go back
so so what I'm saying is it is it
possible to go suppose that suppose that
somebody gives inputs X Y Z is it would
there be a forward algorithm are fun ugh
algorithm order you want to call it that
that that systematically evaluates
something and when it gets to the end
the list of stuck at faults on on you
and then convey will be the stuck-at
faults for the whole for the whole thing
but going forward not going back to
performing i think there might be a
forward only algorithm is something
Spurs idea to circuit with them was up
stuck at fault yeah I was imagine that
you had both seen for example both a and
a prime which and then a prime is using
all the outputs of a or a bar get works
someone ends up and I guess you just
changed the circuit so that after that
point to use you use a a prime instead
okay let's finish this problem in any
way first what about this is is this a
stuck at 0 is that actually detected by
this particular input it is because of
we know it doesn't depend on Z it comes
comes through to change you okay and see
stuck at 0 on scene stuck at 0 would get
through to B because b is not known but
b is 0 so this one doesn't come through
eating roots right because the other
organ oh it's an audacious accuse me
okay
oh it i consider it might be a valuable
thing to work out a fast algorithm for
figuring out the solution to this
problem I'm not sure it is or not but my
intuition says its interest to start out
with a with a with a given input and to
compute the set of all stuck at faults
that it will do it by some reasonably
fast calculation it goes it goes from
the bottom to the top there is a
top-down approach also to the to the
stuck-at faults in this is a mississippi
suppose for example at it but i wanted
to say that it does v depend on on a i
wanted to i want to show this quickly
because we're running on a time but
support but v it support vehicle is a
function of the inputs x y and z and we
can take any boolean function and write
it in various canonical forms you can
write it booming function as in
disjunctive normal form for example and
so on and end but since we've got a lot
of exclusive oars i think the the from
that writes it as a as like exclusive
and and gates and forgets and
gets a grid of all the or gates is a it
is a nice of canonical form this is the
same as polynomial modulo 2 so if you
have only exclusive or and end times
this is the same as working in modulo 2
arithmetic over 20 and 1 and and so x
times X and Y is X Y X exclusive or wide
x + y + X or Y is X plus y plus X Y and
and so we can we can think of this as a
polynomial any of the any of the gates
the vet the result
any gate nursery is a polynomial in the
inputs X Y Z where we just take the
value of the problem you'll modulo 2 and
you can and if we look at at the at this
thing if we imagine that a a particular
gate in the circuit was an input or I'm
really considering it as a prime and I
imagine that that this connects to v by
using a prime when instead of a on the
output lines and ever used a as an
output but I just have all the inputs
coming through except where wherever
they go through a I I stop the path well
this was thin this would be a XYZ times
on let's say f of X Y Z plus G of X Y Z
where I've replaced the polynomial on
XYZ by a polynomial in a XY and z a is
the actually distance I guess I should
leave out the eight this should be a is
the is the result of out gate a and and
and it's been combined with other or
with other polynomial so f and g are
polynomials that a is the coefficient it
do but but a neither the terms that have
an a in them and these are the terms
that don't now the the condition that a
is recognizable in the output is it is
then what what's the condition that if I
let's take let's actually do the
calculation so let you see what I'm
getting at here so v is equal to B or C
so that beans and excellent the plus is
a is exclusive or yeah my addition mod 2
so this is v plus C plus b c d is equal
to XY oh well let me so the XY plus C
plus X Y C and C is equal to AZ so this
is XY plus AZ plus XY AZ
now if we continue if we take any output
and keep expanding until we get two
inputs but I never expand a because a is
the gate i'm testing to see whether
stuck or not then i can fit then i can
write this as a i can factor out Z plus
X Y Z plus XY the part that don't dip
that that guy x in the part that is not
x it and this is just polynomial
arithmetic which we know is is
legitimate to work with clown on it this
way although it happens to also apply
the boolean functions now now this is
what I called F and this is what i call
g any function any any output and any
date i can i can decompose as a as that
gate times some polynomial in the inputs
plus another term right Sonia of f2 I
thought you was yeah F equals one is
that is it is sufficient to say that
this gate does affect the output that's
the necessary and sufficient condition I
think it's a nice algebraic condition as
well went to get it ring it up today so
so with F is zero then then they then
you know it as a function of the input
say XYZ if after zero this is the case
that a is not getting through the output
it off but if F is 1a is definitely
getting to the output because changing
aid from from 120 is going to complement
the develop the offer and so in order to
have a as a stuck at 0 fault it's less
sense of Asia to have F equal to 1 and a
1 and 4 x + 4 hey stop that one it's F
equals 1 in a equals 0 0 though that
those are the conditions for a I think
those of it probably the nicest debate
conditions for stuck at over 400 k to
get a pretty big
personal that's right so so symbolic
power multiplication is not she is not
the answer here but but formally it
gives you an essence which condition
that you can use to derive algorithms
but I'm not recommending multiplying and
getting terms with two to them I mean I
was to the 400th possible salman iqbal
monomials here that we that we then add
add together adding or not cook so this
isn't going to be these expressions will
get large but but the probity derivation
however give us a beer image database
stuff the vase other mental okay even if
you could find the expression invisible
it wasn't some nice analytical form it
might be rather difficult to drag the
input condition which would lead to all
the input conditions which you need to
it becoming one all the input conditions
I would lead to it becoming one yeah but
on the other hand well let's take a look
at so you have a large circuit and it
turns out that for for 200 of the gates
f is trivial for example suppose you
consider a special case of F consisting
of 0 or 1 terms okay it might turn out
that ninety percent of your gates have
that condition for you know in this
particular case we noticed that for
example that a always got through the
output because I mean but off of you
because its coefficient hand
or this this Z here if items if I could
you do is equal to long a exclusive or
disease which is eight which is just a
plus V so the coefficient is 1 so it's
so sudden and if the coefficient is
equal to an end of any number of terms 0
and more terms then it's a pretty simple
case so so you might be able to use this
algebra for for a great vast majority of
look of the thing and then then you have
then then then using a more complex
method for another one with this yeah so
anyway thinking worst case is not always
it's not always the right way to go
solve a NP complete problem because then
you're worried about things that that
might not not even arise in your
particular problem I don't want to
minimize the importance of
np-completeness but I do want to say
that almost every problem that's ever
been solved or both that there are
things that are worse than NP complete
those are unsolvable problems problems
that there is no algorithm for at all
but on adventure say that almost every
problem that that you've ever sound is a
special case of some unsolvable problem
and that's the fact that that FERC
around I mean and calculus for example
up via the to test whether or not a
function the limit of a function of
enemies is 0 as n goes to infinity is an
algorithmically unsolvable problem but
that hasn't stopped us from doing a lot
of calculus a lot of the functions that
we could actually evaluate the limit
okay um now I hope this has helped some
to get to get your mind thinking about
problem 3
the last thing how about teams is
everybody got teams now for this one and
raise your hand if you're not yet a
member of a team for the problem 3
because we're pipe repair it will
prepare those people together ok you're
now a member of a team for problem three
and so we have all our teams for
problems it so that's it for today and
thursday is our big is a big field trip
I'm going further detailed